there's a lot of noise on social media
from certain Corners talking about the
oppression of women um women today are
oppressed the patriarchy is evil stuff
like that okay Lori shaking her head
that's a no no um it's definitely I
don't believe that no okay why I don't
believe that uh women are oppressed in
our today's society whatsoever if
anything we probably have an
advantage what sorts of advantages do
women have that men don't have uh um
well there's um quotas to hire women
number
one so I really believe and also um men
I feel in this day and age have a major
disadvantage because of this talk of the
patriarchy and dominance and and whatnot
and I really celebrate men I believe men
built this country they invented things
they're the ones that created the laws I
I have a lot of respect for men I
definitely believe that men are the
prize in our society 100% I'm not a
feminist whatsoever okay not at all and
I think that women have sometimes an
unfair Advantage even just to get a
job because they're a woman all right
Ellen do you have any thoughts on that
um I guess to kind of like go off of
that I know I've seen
somewhere like recently that like when
it comes to men and women in their 20s
from like what it is right now women are
actually making a slight bit more than
men in their 20s yeah they're more
educated and they make more
money so you know this whole you know
like men make more than women I think
we're starting to get past that now
and that claim is kind of outdated
currently um still out there there's
still a lot of people making that noise
though yeah I mean there's still a lot
of people making that noise but from
what I see among my peers that are also
in their 20s I don't quite think that's
accurate now in
204 what's the um what's the vibe like
in Switzerland Anna you know when it
comes to the notion that women are
oppressed the the patriarchy's
evil is that a thing Switzerland or
no not at all they are pretty cool here
but Swiss people are very um they are
not into um that kind of relationship
like woman here Swiss women are not that
feminine how can I say they're very cool
they they have a lot of freedom in a
relationship so they have a lot of
freedom yeah okay so like um
how how describe that are you in the
German part are you in the French part
or uh in the German part German okay so
it's mostly German speaking where you
live yeah okay German women are a little
uh more robust I think is the way to put
it yeah yeah okay that makes sense um
what about the notion of shaming you
know I you know I put this out on
Twitter you know last week where I was
saying that shayang act Works uh broke
shaming [__] shaming fat shaming it
motivates Behavior I think it's
something that's uh ingrained in our DNA
I think our grandfathers and
great-grandfathers and
great-grandmothers and you know so on
and so forth used it to motivate
their uh lineage you know their their
kids and their grandkids like you know
they would tell their uh granddaughters
don't be promiscuous you know save
yourself and don't share your body with
a bunch of men they will tell
the boys make something out of yourself
you have to learn these skills learn how
to make money you have to provide and
protect you know sort of things so I
think the notion of of uh fat shaming
[__] shaming and broke shaming um are
being eroded they're being taken away
from us and being called evil or
dangerous or harmful you know in some
regards and respects I'm curious as to
what you ladies think about
that I hear you there because um I grew
up that way as well um we were
definitely told not to uh become
overweight you want to be successful in
life and be smart and carry yourself a
certain way present yourself a certain
way and um I do agree with you there
with the shaming part of it it does
change people I really believe
that what do you think alen to do
better I
mean it's hard to hear sometimes the
feedback but at the same time it's like
how else are you going to be signaled in
order to know that you have to
grow you
know is shaming still a thing in
Switzerland Anna it's I think shaming is
everywhere thing and also s social media
grow grow that paast people are shaming
with um
without shame like they don't they don't
feel nothing like they they be rude on
the internet commanding with fake
accounts just to um I don't know what
people do that actually so going on
going off on someone just because it
looks different so right so I so I mean
here's the um clip that I wanted to
reference just uh 30 seconds long it's
just these girls talking
about we're fat girls of course of
course we're going to ask for a table
instead of a booth we're fat girls of
course I ordered enough to have
leftovers we're fat girls of course I'm
learning to honor my Hunger cues we're
fat girls of course we save some for
later we're fat girls of course we take
up space sorry not
sorry we're fat girls of course we're
unlearning generational fat
phobia we're fat girls we're worthy
exactly as we
are um now internet gave people so much
power
well it it's you know it's empowered
women
to broadcast themselves like there's no
Gatekeepers like there it's it's a
permissionless environment anybody can
upload a video say what they want they
can write a book and publish it you know
and upload it to Amazon without
anybody's permission but now we've got
this um acceptance movement of
normalizing what I would call dangerous
health issues
mediocrity you know what I'm saying like
I'm just curious as to what you ladies
think about stuff like that I believe
there's an epidemic of
um extreme
obesity it's the way our lifestyles are
being led here in the west especially
with fast food um Easy Living um death
jobs we are not living the way humans
should be living I've never seen you
don't see that back in the 1950s and 60s
where people were overweight like that
so um I believe a lot of these women who
are extremely obese are now trying to
and with the media as well empowering
themselves by saying it's beautiful it's
sexy and it's
not we have corporations um
accommodating it you know we've seen
Airlines I think it was Southwest
recently in the last month that said
that they're going to give an extra seat
to essentially morbidly OB that's always
been a thing I'm
I'm six fo Southwest so okay but I'm
tall like I'm six foot2 and I've never
been offered extra leg room right I have
to pay for business class but that's not
something that I can control that's how
I was born you can control your weight
and they're giving people that are
unable to control their weight extra
seating and look at what the airlines
used to be like back in you know when
they first started they were like lounge
chairs back in the day and we've been
sardined into to these cans to make more
money and now we're kind of going in the
reverse where we can just give up a free
seat to an obese person and a person who
actually paid for the seat next to them
gets kicked off that's not
right well this is why it's so laughable
for people to think we don't live in a
gynocentric social order for people to
think that we still live in some sort of
patriarchal male dominated Society
because the people that are championing
these movements fat accept
the alphabet Army movement they're all
women it's you you couldn't make that
video that we just watched with four fat
dudes that weigh 500 pound you couldn't
make that video with men you could
they'd be laughed right off the end they
get death threats I mean they nobody not
a single person on the planet would
think even even short guys will get
mocked routinely by women right they'll
be like ah you know you're only
something they can't even control
meanwhile these hippos are walking
around with this like it's a badge honor
and I mean they've even done I mean
there's there's you're getting to a
point now where there's been these fat
influencers that are dying celebrating
themselves all the way into an early
grave they've got reality shows and
they've got channels and they're dead in
their 30s can I something yeah go
ahead uh this normalizing thing it's the
wor the worst move or thing ever because
you can't normalize everything you can't
like people if you you can't normalize
being fat you can't normalize being
pedophile you can't normalize creating a
third kind of human like and if you say
something you're homophobe
like this is going out of control people
need some values some some shaming is
needed for someone so it's you have you
have to being raised and under um if you
believe in God so you have some
standards you have some values you
respecting someone and all the stuff
this is if someone just have nothing of
them actually they they want everything
like they can do everything and they
want acceptance like you have to accept
that I'm fat and I'm cool and all the
stuff if you say something you are
homophobe
so this normalizing thing this is just
not okay it's not right I really hope
you guys enjoyed that clip if you you
want to watch the full length podcast
you can find that over here that clips
from if you're new to the channel make
sure you hit subscribe over here and pin
down below in the top comment you'll
find a bunch of useful links to my
website my supplement line books and a
bunch of other stuff have an amazing day
peace out